now I look at these SJW type people and
what do they really want they want mommy
and daddy to say I'm proud of you
yep they desperate but but they hate
their parents they want to be loved
everybody wants to be loved everybody
wants to be cherished and feel a part of
something you know and now they they're
a part of something it's a cult that's
what causes it yeah cults do cults it
filled the void it railed the void that
they were thirsting for they were like
oh yeah yeah come on we got you we love
you here yeah this is actually one
reason why I've thought maybe religion
is really important mm-hmm
because at least with the modernization
you know Christianity and Judaism you
have peace that's a good point like yeah
we had thousands of years of war in
conflict but now you look at modern
Christianity and it's like you know yeah
we'll just sitting at home having
Christmas and kind of minding their own
business one of my best friends is you
know he goes to church and he runs a I
forget what he calls it but it's it's
basically just a group of you know any
any kid that doesn't have a dad it's a
bunch of dads go and they all have like
a bad day you know like come and well
you know we hang out we do you know
manly stuff it's kind of like Boy Scouts
but for yeah like big brother you know
and it's like it's in the Christian
Church or you know whatever church he
goes to and it's like through them and
it's not really religious they don't
talk about religion they just do you
know they play games they they talk
about what's bothering them and it's
like that's awesome it's like I'm not
religious but I can get behind that like
we need we need that kind of stuff in
communities you know that that's gonna
help solve a lot of issues you know well
the way I see it is you know I grew up
Catholic briefly okay left the church
not very interested in it I'm looking at
it now like wow when you remove that
from people they fill it with really
nasty stuff yeah there's like a hole and
people are looking for something there a
lot of people probably are scared scared
of death and then you can have someone
whisper sweet nothings into your ears
and it can be a reformed modern religion
that tries to tell people to do better
doesn't mean they always do or it can be
a death cult that tells you everyone as
evil and everyone hates you and
everything must burn yeah and so now you
have these people trying to burn
everything even an Elk's
you even an elk statue just just to burn
it just destroy it yeah so it's like
they're there unwinding all of these
things we have built that's me miss evil
you wanna know why is evil
tell me Tim you know you want to know
what the the purpose of life is yes I do
know desperately seeking answers me
especially what you think it is well I
can't tell you what meaning means oh
come on I can't tell you that life does
one thing hop out life organizes free
energy into complex systems and it
creates ever-ever it actually increases
the level of complexity so it's almost
like within an entropic system we have
life which is negative entropy in a
sense so basically you take a look at
the building blocks of the universe okay
and everything you know entropy
everything is slowly dissipating
eventually we'll find will face the heat
death of the universe
yeah or the opposite what is what's the
opposite the the big cold they call it
the big cold yeah because the the
universe is expanding so eventually I
mean I'm that is the I mean eventually
but there everything will be so far away
from each other you won't see any other
stars the heat death there's no more
heat there's no more transfer of energy
okay each electron is evenly spaced out
to the point where nothing interacts
ever again yeah you can't yeah so that's
where we're headed based on what weaker
and thing currently think however for
now as things do spread out there are
still interactions between baser
particles which form atoms elements
compounds etc and so over you know
throughout everything we can see as you
know what life and existence is there
are bits of random free energy that
combine to form more complex things be
it more electrons or neutrons or protons
all the way up to compounds then
eventually you get to the point where
life starts to exist which is the ever
increasing complexity of existence yeah
so you first and this is based on me Who
I am I am NOT a scientist I'm study the
stuff but you have self-replicating
proteins that emerge and all these are
are chemicals that just copy each other
and so they're taking free energy bits
and going sticking them together some
somehow somewhere it becomes cellular
life and so at the very base you know
base of regular
life there taking chemical bits and
turning it into more complex systems
that function and reproduce eventually
get multicellular so now it's even more
complicated where each individual cell
now combines with other cells eventually
that that you know becomes an organism
so then you get basic really small
microorganisms as they increasingly
become more and more complicated
absorbing for energy and creating more
complex systems you get to the point
where this this life creates a system
outside of itself an ecosystem so now
you have squirrels planting nuts become
trees which make more nuts which feed
the squirrels so now the life is
interacting between each other then you
get to the point where the live shots
manipulating the environment
beavers building dams etc these building
nests birds building nests and then you
come to the point where rat now human
beings who create Stratcom plex systems
we don't just reproduce by eating things
and turning into more people we don't
just create physical objects we also
name those objects give them ridiculous
amounts of names like you can just you
know the word run has I think like 50
plus definitions we create ridiculous
abstract constant competition the
develop that you know and in in the
sense that we connect we don't actually
create matter out of nothing but the the
creation of new complex systems is
something we can build and can create
over time we do our best to create more
than we destroy these people seek only
to destroy true which is the opposite of
what life does and that's what I feel
like we we're supposed to do we're
supposed to build new complex systems
and improve upon them so that they help
new systems grow and it's in a sense
resisting the entropy of the universe we
won't win that fight yeah but we're
trying harder and harder and harder to
do better and better and better we
become more efficient we we simplify
language we simplify math we simplify
our programming languages so they become
increasingly more complex but more
capable then antiph on the far left
shows up and tries to destroy everything
around us to me that is the opposite of
what life does and that's why it's
inherently evil its destructive it hurts
people that hurts us it hurts our
creations our developments and in the
end it leaves us in pain you know they
burn down an elk statue for a literally
no reason its destruction for no reason
it builds nothing it creates nothing it
hurts
everyone and it's gone now yeah I don't
like it disappeared right oh really
yeah it's not there anymore so that's
that's that's that's why I view these
people they have no plan yeah they're
not trying to create anything they're
not trying to improve anything they are
in fact trying to make everything harder
for everybody yeah and then in the fight
to say that it's it's trying to make it
equal for everybody oh that's that's the
the insidiousness I guess mm-hmm that
you think that what they're actually
doing is so many people are like but
they're anti-fascist Oh in the most
fashion fashion a possible vicious stick
oh I'll be fair okay cuz I'll avoid the
proper noun that is fascism okay
it's authoritarianism it's it's it's
very much similar there's a famous
anarchist professor I'm gonna void
leaves name i ee tweeted about this that
many elements of the left have adopted
fascistic philosophies yep in order to
to gain power before we get too far away
what the whole that was beautiful how
you talked about basically the evolution
of life on the planet and I the whole
time all I wanted to do is praise the
Sun but do the arms up well the Sun is I
couldn't energy I know it's amazing very
basic for energy yeah very powerful
energy yeah and so when that stuff hits
earth a whole bunch of different systems
are created mm-hmm it's like it's it's
that energy is that the what we use to
build all the little tiny bits on this
planet are taking that up using that
energy like a solar panel to make stuff
I mean that's how we survive because the
plants eat the Sun the Sun we the
science that animals eat the plan to eat
the animal to eat the plants but but
this is why it's it's so important to
create sustainable systems mmm green
energy and things like that you know if
we just keep burning off fossil fuels
we're dish we're putting ourselves at
risk you know but the people who just
burn random things down and tear down
you know statues of abolitionists and
beat people they're a chaotic
destructive force that is in the
disinterest of all life it's true all
life yeah because the the you know it
reminds me of where's a twenty eight
days later I guess maybe that's the
movie yeah it's a good movie you've got
in the beginning there's there's like
that that chimp that's infected
and the animal liberation people break
in and they're like we're gonna set
these animals free and they open it and
then the chimp is all infected zombified
and it bites them mm-hmm and that's how
the zombie virus gets out of the general
public that's how I view these people
they're many of them think they're good
intentioned and you've got someone
begging them stop stop we're actually
fighting really hard to make the planet
a better place and they run in like
morons and just blow everything up and
then make everything worse that's the de
Caddick destructive force that is
whatever this weird far-left stuff is
like they're rewinding everything they
want to destroy Mount Rushmore they
don't you race these things they want to
bring back segregation oh they'll lie to
you and say no we don't all actions
speak louder than words
they are already segregating been doing
it for a decade man that's crazy they've
been doing graduation ceremonies it's
ridiculous culture for a long time so
racist yeah yep because you had an
agreement among most people in this
country that we should not segregate but
there were still people on of all races
that were angry that happened Democrats
not necessarily know I mean but
necessary they're there there are there
armed they're out there though they're
Mexican people who you know segregate
there are black people who segregate
there are white people who segregate
mm-hm and most of society was like nah
we're not gonna do that you know we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna be in this
together
well those we let we let our guard down
demand that the difficult the difficult
thing about being for freedom and
liberty is that it's easy to exploit the
goodwill of people who are wanting to
let you do your thing
it's a good point so it's funny there's
there's always these free speech
conundrums right what's the what's the
right now the BBC has banned black lives
matter buttons I guess right because
they found out that there's their link
to different things that they are not
okay with any more and so I'm seeing a
bunch of a bunch of people say we're all
the free speech you know activists to
defend this now and I'm like do they
have free speech in the UK they don't
right I think it's implied free speech I
don't think they have the same way we do
right so they don't like kinda Nikhil
got arrested but offer that for the for
the pub joke mm-hmm but my response to
this is like first of all I will
absolutely defend your right to free
speech if you want to wear that button
on TV the BBC shouldn't be allowed to
ban it
I don't think that would fly in the US
if it was a public broadcaster like you
know NPR or something
however do you really think that most
people are going to rush to the fent to
the defense of people who are trying to
shut down their free speech no this is
the inherent problem with being for
freedom you will defend someone as they
scream kit like like they'll be poignant
you saying screaming don't let him speak
everyone shut him down scream in his
face and then when the cops come and
start yelling at them the good guys the
freedom-loving people say no no he
should be allowed to keep saying it so
what does that mean they're entitled to
rally people to shut you down and
principally you must allow them to do it
it's a good point it's a problem yeah no
there you go man
I believe they have a right to say it
guess what because they do they use it
and use it against us and so long as we
believe in that principle they will
exploit it because authoritarianism has
a major advantage over libertarianism
right China can weld people in their
homes and shut down a play a pandemic
and harvest do they harvest organs of up
people that they hold in camps yep they
can make people eat gutter out of the
sewer you know then lock people up and
do everything want to him hmm and that's
no way to live man man being treated
like just a waste by-product
you know you seen the movie the island
yeah with Scarlett Johansson and with
Ewan McGregor yeah for those aren't
familiar it's basically I mean the
movies 20 years old boiler spoilers uh
they there's these people who live in
this facility and they're very childish
and naive and they think when you win
the lottery you get to go to what like
the island or something you get to go to
the island yeah but in reality when you
and a lot of rates because outside of
this facility the actual human who had a
clone of them made to harvest organs
wants your organs it needs the organ
yeah yeah so what ends up happening is
like these people live they're not
realizing they're actually clones and
then when someone's liver fails they
like chop them open take the liver or
the pregnant woman that basically
carried the baby term yeah where her
clone yeah she was the clone rather yeah
yeah yeah so yeah man that's that's
that's how you're treated in
authoritarian systems mm-hmm like just
like a number you don't matter if films
from
mmm-hmm didn't work last time well I'll
tell you what man I got bad news for you
it seems like we're heading in that
direction I don't think so listen
there's a lot of freedom-loving people
but it's funny
i-i've been saying a lot that people
should stand up for themselves people
like I tweeted about the silent majority
yeah and everyone keeps trying to make
it seem like when I say speak up I'm
saying go out and physically fight or
something right and I think these people
are doing this because they don't want
moderates and conservatives and even
actual liberals to speak up for
themselves so it's it's like the the
only thing available right now is either
you can shut up and let them take over
and when I say stand up for yourself
they're like he's calling for violence
he's going from violence help help it's
like no I'm just saying people that
should tell you to shut up they want
they want that dichotomy so that they
have a monopoly on violence you know and
there's nothing you can do about it
but like I said man peaceful protest is
more effective if you stand up it's like
that's what Martin Luther King believed
in and he was a boss at it he made it
work and I wonder why it is he's more
revered to the general public than
Malcolm X's no no no it's the violence
issue it's the issue it's the issue of
violence that's probably a it's a it's
funny I think Malcolm X condemned
liberals and I think Martin Luther King
condemned moderates interesting yeah
they both you know whatever they were
both civil rights leaders in their own
right but most people are unfamiliar
with Malcolm X yeah I don't even know
much about him other than people have
told me that he was more in favor of
being violent and fighting back whereas
Martin Luther King jr. is more about
passive resistance you know and some of
disobedience I wonder if that's why we
we actually you know remember him more
fondly I guess probably yeah they were
both killed right I think so pretty sure
you know I don't know where had men you
know so I did a segment on my main
channel today about what if nope what if
what if everybody loses what if Trump
and Biden both lose there's an
interesting so remember we talked before
about what could cause the civil war if
I could if Trump wins so here's what I
said Trump could win the electoral
college by a little bit and then some
some swing state has a Democrat governor
who then says No
we're gonna give our votes to the
popular winner so then Trump and Biden
both declare victory
Newsweek wrote an article saying the
inverse that both Trump and Biden lose
and if they both lose then what happens
is it goes to the House of
Representatives based on state
delegations the Republicans have the
majority okay so based on the amount of
reps you get I don't know that that
works but basically what they said was
it would be 26 to 23 in terms of
delegations and the Republicans would
win so if Biden Trump don't clear 270
the House of Representatives votes and
Trump has guaranteed the Republican
winner okay so what the way they argued
it was that Trump will claim there's
voter fraud in one of these swing states
okay
ah there's four swing states that have
Republican control of their state
legislatures so they're they're arguing
Trump will claim voter fraud the state
legislators will vote and say we must
investigate that will jam up the
Electoral College which won't vote in
time so these four states will be
removed putting both Trump and Biden
under 270 then the House of
Representatives votes Trump wins that's
their argument you know and if that
happens chaos I mean we are it's 2020
it's 2020s motto is is chaos I hate yet
bringing aliens and mostly they're here
people are saying they're there in Miami
they're flying around New York or there
somewhere I don't know I haven't seen
yet though it's just you know somebody
goes off Krakatoa goes out come cool
meteor slams in their grips right
through it the aliens come in yo stop
people get raptured America don't know
where they go is gone basically yeah so
that's it's basically turning America
into one big volcano you know it would
be cool if all of the the weird
apocalypse and arrows happen the exact
same time yeah cool Tim so cool yeah I'm
just I'm just I'm just ready for it on
the asteroid will come you get massive
global warming so the oceans start
rising you know then then a giant
asteroid slams into the earth while
aliens are
then Yosemite goes off what else happens
they clone dinosaur they figured out a
clone dinosaurs this is true by the way
this they actually have claimed they can
they can clone dinosaur I don't know if
they happy erectus walks into your city
and then like eats a guy in your life
honey I don't even know it's 20 20 men
yeah I got it
when Mentos are you listening to me you
know remember the Mentos commercials
where like they would get away with
doing things yeah as long as her eating
Mentos like committing crimes is okay
breaker yeah I remember one where it's
like there's a guy who wants to park his
car but he can't and so then like he
hires a bunch of construction workers to
lift someone's car up so he can put his
car there and the guy looked at the
window he's like what are you doing in
my car and the guy and the guy shows
Mentos and pops in his mouth and I start
laughing my most commercial I do yeah
vaguely that's what it's basically like
right now it's like but instead it's
like it's 2020 you know like having
Mentos no no but her I'm burning this
out statue Mentos yeah like aliens come
and crash into a building and there's
like people fling in there shooting
people and then just the aliens are
actual Mentos bars no no no it's like
that idea it's like giant sized mentos
eyes
not literally Mentos you know but the
idea is that great no matter what
happens like I'll put it this way you're
robbing a bank and the cop runs and he
goes drop the weapon and you hold up a
calendar and you point to 2020 in the
cop goes and you just drug and then you
walk out with bags of cash like that's
funny man you know whatever it's all you
know you steal someone's car and they're
like well you're stealing my car like
it's 2020 they're like good points
good wine never right here's the keys
yeah then they high-five you yeah
chaos isn't fun that's that sounds
terrible
I don't know man does it a little bit
yeah waiting I can't stand well how
often have we have you been joking about
giant meteor of death just slam into the
earth and just wiping us all out I mean
not that often but the in the past eight
years giant meteor has bumper stickers
it has started to try to Mordor yeah
that's true
yeah put Trump's face on the asteroid
and I have I'm just yelling China and
like a streak of fire behind him of his
slams into the earth it's the business
the best asteroid I'm the biggest
asteroid I'll wipe out everything
everybody agrees it's over no one will
survive yeah I gotta say though you know
I've been I've been talking to people
about this stuff and you can't help but
want to be a conspiracy theorist in
times like this it's true so you've got
Co vid what you know it's just like I
don't know anybody who's had it I don't
know anybody who has it I traveled
across the country I got tested for it I
didn't have it yeah I've never seen
anybody I don't know anybody who has it
and that's just me I'm not saying it
exists what's weird is the death ray
everyone's talking about that everyone's
got it now there's the the amount of
people that have it skyrocketing that
the rate is gone but the death rate has
consistently dropped and is still
dropping and still sits still almost
it's almost nothing now no I you the
weird thing to me is June 9th I think it
was mhm
they said or is it maybe the third very
a symptomatic transfer is very very rare
we haven't we haven't seen it huh
interesting that was June 3rd for the
world health world health organization
so then I was like oh okay so max masks
are pointless yeah then they were like
oh but you got to wear it and I'm like
but you just said if we don't have
symptoms we can't transmit it yeah but
you wear your mask
oh my do you just want everybody wear
masks is that is that what you're on
about I don't care how it's keeping the
fear so they can blame it on Trump so
that they'll pull Trump votes if it
wasn't an election year at yo conspiracy
measure you're not it's an election year
and things go crazy on election years
nothing makes sense that makes a lot of
sense to me like remember when I was
I've been I've been saying the Democrats
want Trump to win I don't know if that's
true listen man when you tell the
American public that protesting is
allowed but but cutting hair isn't or
going to church isn't right so they say
they say the council tuition you can't
sing in church that's weird you can
protest or black lives matter right
regular people are gonna freak out about
that yeah that's this country is still
majority Christian and they're gonna be
like what's not only can you protest but
protesting doesn't cause a spike of
virus they're making a point to slam
this home you can go out and protest it
doesn't cause it to spread so it's like
if that's true then why can't we just go
do go about our business
even if sure we'll wear masks I got I
don't even mind I'll wear a mask I don't
care but let us do our thing open
businesses up I got bad news what is it
Facebook has stripped me of my hope in
humanity
oh no why because it's just all of these
people regurgitating garbled nonsensical
talking points I know I'm seeing it all
the time like I said where the guy was
like Doha what'd the government just you
know like pay people like the yeah I
just just pay like you what yeah there's
no idea how any of this stuff is made
where it comes from it's just like foods
just there yeah government can give you
cheese Facebook is just filled with with
bad articles poorly written basically
opinions citing science that isn't
proven memes that claim to prove a point
but literally just have a sentence on
them and they're like look at this meme
it shows that this this happened right
I'm like wow that you're spreading that
around a lot do you know that's not true
right I don't care if it's true I don't
care I don't like you anymore
yeah how dare you man you're racist it's
like that comic where it's like I had
I'm racist are you kidding me
you you have no idea who I am none if
you're calling me racist but you're
white
sure how's the new rules bro I don't
make it up I don't they're not it's not
law I'll tell you what man that's crazy
whenever crazy rules whenever I'm
talking to my work friends about the
stuff yeah like in person mm-hmm I
always like pulling the the black
propaganda card you know black web I get
black propaganda is explain please
it's it's where you pretend to be in
favor of something I know make it seem
insane okay so like if you dressed up
like an intersectional feminist then
went around screaming you know like
killing people and stuff people be like
wow these people are crazy I don't have
anything to do with them okay even
though you're not really for it it's a
trick but what I like what I like doing
is I just say something like when they
start talking about this stuff I'll be
like oh dude yeah I'm totally down I'll
be honest with you guys you know I come
from a mixed-race family so I'm looking
forward to when you guys are
second-class citizens right you'll have
no job you'll work for me and do
whatever I want and you guys will be
answering to whatever I whatever
I want to do and their life wait wait
one no but yeah you're why I'm the
smallest minority in the country the
smallest minority is people of mixed
race background so all of these woke
white people that are preaching this
stuff I'm like I look forward to you
cleaning my dishes and kissing my feet
well I do like working for you though
I'll be honest it's pretty cool job is
just to sit there and like you know talk
about your feelings yeah like we both
just complain to the in it for a living
it's not that yeah I do like poking you
a little bit yeah whatever man it's a
show that's the point it gets you right
what do you think like these these white
people think they're entering a world
where they'll have power or something
yeah and I'm like oh no you won't you
know I'll be okay you know I'll be fine
right you know I'll just grow my facial
hair to get tan for two seconds and
Bryce and I get all the benefits that
you're you're espousing and I'll just
pretend to support you because then I
get your money right you have to pay me
over the world hey man your ancestors
created those miscegenation laws and and
and racial covenants so at what point
you know is it the question I have to
like it's a crazy cold ah it's crazy
though because only like 16 percent of
the world is white people yes Yeah right
I was like wow that's a crazy statistic
I had no idea even even in there nuts
even in America and in Europe ya know
that's combined
no no thing is even in these countries
you have large non-white populations yes
you're not true for China not true for
Japan right not true for almost every
single other country on the planet so
whatever that means
I'll tell you what these people seem to
think that they're gonna get access to
power or something by putting these
rules into place does it stop with
Confederate stores statues the answer no
right these people have no line it then
goes on to ulysses s grant Thomas
Jefferson George Washington does it stop
with presidents well because Grant was a
slave owner he had one slave did free
the man then it goes to the abolitionist
Union soldier who died in battle to free
the slaves does it stop with with human
beings the hundreds of thousands of
soldiers that fought to free the slaves
it they will they burnt they tore down
the one statue of the guy no right but
it doesn't stop with humans they'll burn
down the elk statute
here's my question will reparations stop
with just the black community no way
right hey man hey hey hey my family my
mixed-race family yeah was oppressed was
unable to build wealth because it was
illegal and were forced to flee
different states because of racial
covenants and racist laws therefore my
family is entitled to money from your
pocket hey whoa specifically oh no no no
my family wasn't even here during
censoring all that that was going down
they came they came after after it all
so it's like I don't know what what did
I do like my dad didn't matter your well
okay sure that means you got to give me
money we're set hundred dollars I gave
you give it back that's mine now all
right I don't I don't actually I think
it doesn't make sense I think my family
greatly benefited I think even if there
were bad laws that held us back they
escaped something worse
now we've live in a beautiful country
right now where anyone who wants to work
hard towards something they want to do
they can do it that's the world we live
in these people don't want to work hard
they want to scream at other people and
have everything handed to them which is
what they're used to and they have no
idea that when the system falls apart
they won't have anything they're gonna
cry and they will cry and I'll probably
die it because they won't be
self-sufficient they'll be asking others
for for the things that they're used to
how they're privileged to have that they
don't realize that they have they have
no idea what's going on around the world
now they have no idea slavery still
exists in over a hundred countries yeah
do you know what a millions of people
millions and millions of people are
slaves right now millions and and that's
that's only like two or three different
countries millions of people you know
slavery still exists in the United
States to really trafficking that's true
human trafficking are these are people
who are who are consorted as property
and it happens it's true oh I got crazy
I've heard about we've tracked some
crazy stories particularly with the
Native American reservations and what
people do I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
get into fine details but man these are
horrific things still exist today yeah
that's messed up and instead of talking
about shutting these things down they're
like we could be talking about the
horrifying things that happen at
reservations that the FBI won't go after
because it's not
they don't care mm-hmm instead they're
like Bert break break apart Mount
Rushmore it's like okay you know there's
like innocent people being tortured and
kidnapped so we could you know I don't
know focus on that for a minute I'm down
now I don't want to do it so here's what
I think man well I I almost you know
part of me wants then you just finally
get their way you know why because there
are a lot of people in this country who
are crazy there are a lot of people in
this country who are very fit mm-hmm
very well-armed and very angry very
crazy very aggressive you know they wish
they were Alexander the Great they wish
they were Ganga's Khan and when the
system all falls apart no one will stop
them
what do you think happens in the Pacific
Northwest with these whiny little babies
and there's no government you're gonna
see warlords yeah I already almost saw
it and she has yeah he claims he he was
like a they they appointed him he didn't
like go in that's that's that's it
that's right that's true there's gonna
be it's gonna happen anyway there's
gonna be one guy and he's gonna walk in
and he's gonna be like we're gonna make
this work and I'm and you're gonna do it
my way and he's gonna start telling him
what to do and everybody you can't tell
me what to do and there's gonna go pop
anyone else you know get to work yeah
and they're gonna be okay okay like oh
man what but they don't understand that
you are accountable we were supposed to
yeah exactly when the when police do
things wrong guess what videos pop up
everywhere is not perfect and also it's
not racial they want to fight to the
death that it's racial and it's evil on
even outside of that at the very basic
level even though there is police
corruption sorry but it's there is an
open door no matter what the cops do to
try and get justice but if we devolve
into warlord territory with no
government there's no justice if you
know some guy starts just some crazy guy
who's got a ton of guns everything falls
apart he's a he and he calls himself
like the hook he's like this is my
territory who do you complain to right
when he walked up to you and says which
one he was cleaning the toilets and
you're like hey man use America and he
goes bang it's you and then you're like
my friend is dead tell someone who cares
yep they've never been to countries like
this you know I when I was in Morocco I
told you the story the I'm in the taxi
cab heading to the airport earlier I was
in the morning and the guys blowing
every speed every stoplight and then
he's like if we stop they robbed us
and I was like oh yeah that's what
happens there well thanks for going oh I
say wait for you to stop and then they
run up to you with guns pointing and so
he just you guys to beat through him you
guys beat through him Wow man there are
countries where the cops will steal your
stuff they'll kidnap you they'll you
know they'll Tec take your money from
your wallet yeah but they don't get it
man because they're too comfortable i
they've had it too good yep
that's it's we are wrong men good times
good times weak men weak men hard times
we don't we're in the hard times they're
weak now not yet well right if we if it
keeps going down this path there will be
hard time yeah we're on the run that run
that we're like the roller coaster just
come to the top yeah we're looking and
and we don't got to go over the edge
baby but it looks like we're gonna go
over the edge and yeah cuz even if Trump
wins and brings back that really great
economy that he had for the for the past
few years these people gonna go nuts and
burn everything down and so it's just
gonna be chaos no matter what happens I
mean actually I think if Biden wins they
just slowly take over and then the life
sucks so it's gonna be pretty awful yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you